حيث اعلن الدفاع المدني السوري منطقه
الشماليه غرب سوريا منطقه من كوبا بعد
الهزات الارضيه التي شهدتها المنطقه
مراسله في مدينه ادلب صهيب الخلف رافق
فرقه دفاع المدني ووفانا بالتقرير
نحن الان في مدينه ادلب نهار هذا المبنى
بعد الهزات الارضيه التي طالت المنطقه فرق
الدفاع المدني تحاول هنا منذ حوالي اكثر
من ساعه تحاول لرفع الانقاض لان الجيران
هنا يقولون بانهم سمعوا اصوات استغاثه بعد
حدوث الهزات الارضيه من هذا البناء
بالتحديد هذا البناء كان قد تعرض للقصف
لكن نازحين لجاوا اليه وسكنوا فيه بعد
الهزات الارضيه انهار جزء كبير منه فرق
الدفاع المدني تقول انها انتشلت عده قتلى
من هنا وما زالت تحاول البحث عن ضحايا تحت
الانقاض او تحاول انتشال ناجين هناك
عده ابنيه دمرت بشكل كامل في محافظه ادلب
في ريفيا الشمالي تحديدا غير هذا المكان
في مدن الدانه في مدن جسر الشغور وسلقين
وعزمارين هناك احوال كارثيه جدا في محافظه
ادلب جراء الهزات الارضيه التي طالت
المنطقه بعد الزلزال الذي وقع في تركيا
صهيب الخلف الجزيره مدينه ادلب